here we go again black against mr.
Horgan so what is his weapon of choice
this time it's been three anyway so we
don't have to argue there but he plays
different lines yeah this is something
where I think black just has the
advantage for nothing much it's just
like white has given up on any any
opening any hopes of an opening
advantage and like it's just better but
ok we'll see what happens he plays this
stuff like every game which I feel
really is a form of masochism but we'll
see why would you play 1b3 every single
chance game
okay so can we do something direct here
already probably not but jeez 25 I was
thinking about g5 and set of g6 already
but it felt a little bit a little bit
too much
what are you doing here might see 5mm it
looks very slow all this so let's go b6
and ask this night where it wants to go
[Music]
also want to prepare but should be six
yeah okay I can go look be eight or I
can just take that that pawn but taking
the pawn looks looks looks wrong so
let's just keep everything as is
yeah I know what is he doing in c5
trying to install a night on b6 or
something like that if it gives me like
one more move we should be six and then
I playing c5 and white is completely
killed because he has no development
whatsoever now maybe c5 is relatively
best nope okay let's just not waste any
more time it really plays that okay so
how do we how do we do the same age four
I mean age three I mean let's go age
three yeah and Nyjah for how are you
ever going to untangle this position
down I'm really curious about that so we
should be true what's the deal
yeah Queen f6 I wanted to do anyway so
let's do it this should be to order I'm
probably taking that huh whatever to I
[Music]
wonder if I should it's really debatable
that night only six i wonder if i should
try to exchange it or not on the one
hand it's not doing all that much on the
other hand it is quite annoying and then
everyone idea that i think quite good i
want to put the Bishop to g4 trade does
okay so edgy for is a little bit under
too close so maybe here
he's got 97 I just recognized that I
never looked at this stuff stuff on this
side but he has that he has this idea
[Music]
okay
and I'm not so great you're doing great
on the clock ok let's trade that bloody
thing now he wants to play walk to a 6
yeah let's see what happens here taking
you four so he goes back III doesn't
work yet this is not clear
[Music]
time war day okay seven or something no
then I death its sides hanging with
chick this is really an issue okay so i
can fly misplayed that stuff I really
did and I had a complete hallucination
actually which is a bit was very bad i
was thinking i'm on a light screen and
not know he has got King f2 losing this
game this is simply simply awful it's it
was difficult to lose that I managed
check it's amazing
really amazing check check doing here
check check playing that slowly check I
mean I'm not going to offer it all ya
can white forfeits on time anything he
has to offer at least young and all
sorry i isolate yeah i just edges I
didn't take this series anymore after
had this position I have to admit which
is not the right way to do it a horse
pattern yeah I this is just too awful to
white to contemplate but I didn't finish
it I mean it really should be finished
its position and I didn't I just played
all kinds of stuff there on the on the
Kings side without having a totally
clear plan just thinking it would win
itself but it's not it's not that
terrible now look here that the engine
says this is equal which is possible
ready but before this disposition is
simply terrible for white here okay
eight is an idea and okay I think that
this must be still clearly better for
like yeah the engine gives 96-98 trading
dissolve this is probably right that the
night is a bit annoying there'll be six
on the one hand it doesn't do all that
much but it controls a eight and i
probably need this move do to get
through some of infiltrate I mean he's
completely tied down on the Kings side
but it's not made yeah this is a pretty
nice move 498 yeah this is fine but it's
not
I thought also it would be would be
better than it than it is did I miss
anything before that probably not this
is ok I mean I can take a five of course
this is possible maybe this is this is
the reason why this could get this a
tech going bit of a mystery they asked
wanted to my advantage of ways somehow
yeah i still felt it this would be ok ok
route 66 I didn't see this move well we
can take now then create them yeah he
always had this opportunity giant ear
things things kind of Maui's got it
under control and i also had him add
some weird hallucination i was thinking
i'm on a light square they have f to
check summer I was thinking I have this
chick and cringy for which is of course
completely completely idiotic no then
somehow I don't know he's got 10 seconds
more and a completely winning position
if he decides to lose this on time by
not moving what can I do ok thanks for
watching